[MUSIC]
Hello, and welcome to our conference call,
MBA Admissions Insights: Considering
a Joint or Dual Degree.
Thanks for joining us.
My name is Allison Davis, I'm Associate
Director in the MBA Admissions Office.
And I'm joined by my colleague,
Mary Oleksy, Associate Director, Joint and
Dual Degree Programs.
>> Hi, everyone.
>> In the next 30 minutes we'll be
talking about what to keep in mind
as you consider pursuing a joint or
dual degree.
We'll start by reviewing some
of your options as a joint or
dual degree student and then we'll
discuss some questions that you may find
worthwhile to ask yourself before
pursuing a joint or dual degree.
We'll wrap up by answering some of
the questions that you've all submitted
in advance.
So Mary, let's start off with the basics.
Most of this is on our website,
but let's review it here briefly.
To begin, can you tell us the difference
between a joint degree and a dual degree?
>> Yes, so in a joint degree
there's a reduction MBA units and
some MBA units may either be double
counted toward both degrees or
counted towards the other degree.
In order to graduate with a joint degree,
a student needs to meet both
sets of degree requirements.
And I want to note that it takes
an additional one to three quarters beyond
the two years for the standard MBA.
In contrast, a dual degree program is when
a student pursues a second degree with any
other graduate program at Stanford
University that we don't have a formal
agreement with.
There is a reduction in MBA units.
And this allows a student to start earning
credit towards their other degree program.
I want to note that there's no
double counting of units, and
students complete the MBA in two years
when they complete a dual degree.
>> And there are even more options, right?
>> Yes, so beyond what's offered
at Stanford, students may also
pursue degrees with selected professional
schools at other universities.
Right now, our list includes Public
Policy Programs at Harvard, Princeton and
Johns Hopkins along with the Harvard
Medical School, Yale Law School and
Yale Medical School, and
all of these are listed on our website.
I want to note that we don't have formal
dual degree agreements with these schools.
But we do partner with them informally
to offer these as study opportunities.
And what does this mean for you?
It means you need to do the leg work for
these dual study opportunities.
You will need to inquire with each
school regarding its policy and
its timeline for the programs.
>> And why would somebody typically
be interested in pursuing
more than just an MBA?
>> I think in today's complex world
there's more and more recognition
of the intersection and interplay
of business with fields like law,
education, technology and
medicine just to name a few.
Therefore, we know a students interests
and goals may span multiple disciplines.
And we want to nurture that
by providing flexibility and
an opportunity to simultaneously
explore other academic areas.
So it may be helpful to know
that 21% of our current MBA
students are pursuing a joint or
a dual degree.
>> And be aware also that there
are specific application instructions
depending on what type of joint or
dual degree you're interested in.
For example, for the JD/MBA, the MD/MBA,
the joint Master's in Computer Science and
a few others, you would use SAB,
which asks, why Stanford, in
the online MBA application to support your
rationale for the joint or dual degree.
While, for the joint Master's
in Education, you're required to
upload a personal statement in the joint
degrees section of the MBA application.
Again, all this information
is on our website, but
you should be aware of some of
these differences ahead of time.
>> That's absolutely right.
Again, I encourage you all to read
our website, the GSB website,
as well as the website of the other
program you are interested in,
because there are specific
instructions depending on the degree.
And in many cases,
you need to apply separately and
you need to be admitted to both programs.
So for example,
our JD/MBA program with the Stanford
Law School falls into this category.
And then, in other cases such as
the joint Master's degree in Education,
we will forward your application and
personal statement to
the graduate school education.
So please do your homework and
read the website.
>> There may also be
different tests required.
For example,
the MBA program accepts both the GRE or
the GMAT, but the School of Engineering
will only accept the GRE for
Master's degree programs in computer
science and electrical engineering.
And if you're applying as
an international student,
the MBA program will accept the TOEFL,
the PTE, or the IELTS,
while the School of Engineering
will only accept the TOEFL.
>> Yes, all correct.
And again, specific requirements for each
program are listed on the web sites and so
you just want to make sure
you're familiar with that.
>> Mary, I think we should also mention
that applicants should be mindful of
when to apply.
The MBA program has three
application rounds,
with deadlines this year on September 21,
January 10, and April 5.
However, other degree programs may only
have one application deadline, typically,
in mid-December.
The reply date,
which is the date by which you must accept
your offered admission, may also vary.
So you don't want to find yourself in
a situation where you have to decide if
you're accepting your offer of
admission to one degree program
before you know if you've gotten
into the other degree program.
>> Yeah,
I really appreciate you highlighting that.
If you're applying, for example,
to the computer science or
electrical engineering
joined degree programs,
I really recommend that you apply
to the MBA program in round two.
So again,
this is something to be aware of.
You want to make sure you check for each
degree program, not only the application
deadlines but also the date that you'll
receive your admission decision and
the dates where you must accept or
decline your offer of admission.
>> Mary, let's talk about what's your
role in working with students who
are interested in pursuing a joint or
dual degree.
>> Mm-hm, so I work with both current
students and admitted students.
For currently enrolled students,
I provide academic advising and
support with navigating
both degree programs.
I also offer general advising sessions for
admits and students who are considering
applying for a joint or dual degree and
want to talk through those options.
>> And just to be clear, you work
only with MBA students once they're
admitted to the MBA program, and
with current students who are pursuing or
are interested in
pursuing a second degree,
your role is not to advise applicants or
prospective applicants.
>> Yeah, [LAUGH] sorry, that is correct,
I only work with admits and students.
>> All right,
now why don't we back up for a moment and
talk about some questions that
you out there should be asking
yourselves as you're getting ready
to apply for joint or dual degree.
Answering these questions for
yourself now can save you time
later in the application process.
So, of course, first you need
to ask yourself, is a joint or
dual degree right for you?
And how would you suggest
people think about that, Mary?
>> Mm-hm, yeah, and this is important
to spend some time thinking about and
I suggest that you start at a high level.
So let's start with a vision, and
I know that this is going to change for
you many times but, what is your
vision today for your future career?
And do those career dreams include
opportunities or roles where a specific
degree beyond an MBA is either required
for you to get your foot in the door or Or
to be successful in that position,
so you want to think about that.
Another thing to think about is how
important is having those letters and
answer the MA asked you your name?
Sometimes it matters and
sometimes it doesn't.
If the MA or
the MS letters asked you your name or
not as important you want to think about,
what's the content, the experience,
or the context that you need to learn
in order to pursue your vision?
I would also spend some time reflecting
on what you hope to gain from
pursuing an MBA and
from pursuing a joint degree.
And is there room in this vision you have
of what your MBA is going to be like for
the trade offs that you're going to need
to make when you're pursuing a joint
of duel degree program, because there are
some choices that you'll have to make and
you can't say yes to everything.
You also want to think about, are you at
a place in your life where you can make
the time and the financial commitment
to stay for additional quarters beyond
the two years required for the MBA,
because that can be significant.
So do you have personal or
family commitments that you need to
consider when you're making this decision?
But I think all those are important
high level questions to think about.
>> Great.
Next, how do I decide which joint or
dual degree to apply to?
>> Yeah, we have a lot of
interesting programs here.
And so,
I think once you have a clear sense of
what's the subject area that you're
interested in, go do your homework.
I would do some research and
deeply explore both the structure and
the course requirements of the program.
And the question to notice,
when you read through these classes,
do you feel excited about it?
Maybe not every single class, but
you want to test for a sense of alignment
between the program offerings and
your learning goals, so trust your gut.
Something else you want to think about
is your competitiveness as an applicant,
so in general I believe you should
always throw your hat in the ring for
a degree program that
you're interested in.
That being said as with
the MBA applications.
Location, it can also be
a significant time commitment
to pull together a compelling application
for a joint or a dual degree.
It can take hours to prepare for the
exams, requesting recommendation letters,
or writing your responses
to an essay question.
So if it's available, I would take
a look at the admissions criteria or
the statistics for the student body
of the program you're interested in.
To assess, are you a viable candidate for
this program and
would this be a good use of your time?
And I want to highlight that
the advantage of doing a joint or
dual degree program is that you're
going to blend your learning and
you're going to be more efficient with
your time and financial resources.
But the challenge is that you have
to prioritize and make some choice.
Around what is it that you're coming
here to learn, what's the experience you
want to have and how can you fit that
into allotted time that you have.
>> Great, good advice.
People should also think about timing and
ask themselves, should I apply for
a joint redo if degree while
I'm applying for an MBA or
wait until I'm already
student at Stanford.
>> It's an interesting question.
So if your decision to come to Stanford
depends on being accepted to both degree
programs, then you need to apply for
those both in advance of enrolling.
But if you're not totally sure, and you
want to do this Stanford MBA regardless of
what are you are accepted into a second
degree program you can wait and
you could wait in apply during your first
year at the Business School to the other
degree program and
then make your decision.
>> How many students do apply
after they're already here?
About half of our students
pursuing a second degree do that.
So 50/50.
And just as a reminder, the application
requirements like test scores,
essays, etc., all of those things are
the same whether you apply in advance or
whether or
you wait until once you're a student here.
>> Last, if I'm accepted to a joint or
dual degree, how does the timing work,
which program should I start first,
do I even have a choice?
>> So my famous answer, it depends.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> It depends on, and I would refer you to
the website, to our website to see
kind of the pathways and options, for
example medical school students
always start at the med school and
most JD-MBAs start at the law school.
Other programs such as E-IPER,
the masters in public policy or
the MA in education, all those
students will start at the GSB first.
For programs like
electrical engineering and
computer science,
it's more of a personal preference.
So where do you wish to start?
>> Great, Mary.
Let's move on now to answering audience
questions and again thanks to so
many of you for
submitting questions in advance.
So first question, what are the financial
aid opportunities for joint and
dual degree students and how do they
differ from regular MBA students?
>> Yeah, this is a really good question.
So for students pursuing a joint or
dual degree here at Stanford,
you're treated the same
as an MBA-only student when it comes to
determining financial aid eligibility.
Financial aid here is awarded based on
need, and one thing to think about is,
depending on which degree you're pursuing,
it may be best to start at the GSB first,
as we will provide financial aid,
including fellowships, for
the entire time it takes to
complete your joint degrees.
This is a discussion you can have in more
detail with our Financial Aid Office after
you've been admitted.
Let me also note, for those of you
considering study opportunities
outside of Stanford, you are eligible for
financial aid from Stanford only during
the time that you are here for the MBA.
And so, the other institution
would be responsible for
any financial aid you're receiving
while you're attending their program.
And so,
you would need to apply separately.
Lead for
financial aid in that institution.
>> Right.
Are most joint degree students people
who study related fields in undergrad?
>> So not necessarily.
Our technical degree programs like
computer science and electrical
engineering tend to have the most direct
correlation between undergraduate and
graduate experience.
But other programs such as education,
E-IPER, or
public policy, all have a broader
spectrum of undergraduate backgrounds.
>> Will schools confer with each other
during the joint degree admission process?
>> Allison,
I'm going to defer that one to you.
>> Okay, sure.
The admission decisions
are made separately.
We do on our application
form if you have applied or
are considering applying to
a joint degree and which degree.
So we are aware that you may
have applied to another program.
For dual degrees students
need to apply and
be accepted to the other program
separately and then notify our office.
In any case, if you're admitted to the MBA
program and any second degree program,
whether it's a joint or dual degree at
Stanford or one of the selected study
opportunities outside Stanford, Mary, will
be available to answer your questions and
help you map out your schedule of
how you'll pursue the two programs.
Next question, are there specific
number of spots available for
each Joint or Dual Degree program?
>> There are some programs that
have MBA specific cohorts.
So in particular education and
E-IPER will typically accept
approximately 20 to 25 students each year
The cohorts for the other programs are
really based on who they want to accept.
So there is no set number.
>> Can you discuss the computer
science joint degree and
the various careers that people who have
graduated with that degree get into?
>> The CS joint degree is a young program.
We're going into our
third year of existence.
And in speaking with our current students
there is something I want to highlight for
all of you.
So students tell me this
is not a program for
students interested in
being product managers.
What this is, is a program for
students who wish to
take a deeper dive into a specific
area within computer science.
So I would advise you, if you're thinking
about this program, please, go explore
the computer science website and take a
close look at the areas of specialization
because you want to make sure that what
they're offering matches your interests.
And regarding careers, we actually only
have one graduate of the program at
this point, so I don't really have data
yet to share about the career path.
>> And Mary,
would should also probably mention,
in terms of undergraduate backgrounds for
computer science, they really do need
to have a technical undergrad degree.
Is that right?
>> Yeah, they should be highly
quantitative or technical.
So computer science, applied math,
engineering at something in that genre.
>> Or physics I guess is one
that I think is acceptable.
So again, take a look at their website.
But they are looking for people with,
to be competitive applicant you do need to
have a technical under graduate degree.
Next question.
If I join a joint or dual degree program,
will I later be able to drop one and
focus on the other or do I have to
follow through with both no matter what?
>> Yeah.
This is also like a it depends question.
But let me say in general,
it's a difficult position to be and
if you're in a joint degree program and
you're not sure if this is the right path,
and that's why doing your homework now,
on alignment and
program fit is so
important and in general,
if a program is no longer a fit it's
likely you would be able to withdraw.
However, depending on the timing there can
be significant implication on your degree
progress and graduating in time so this
is a decision to be made carefully and
is definitely a decision that students
would consult with me before making.
>> And I think this might be an example of
a situation where you might wait to apply
once you're already
an MBA student here and
you kind of get the lay of the land and
what the work load is and
then apply as a first year student
to that other degree program.
>> Yeah, I agree.
>> How demanding is it
to take a dual degree
if the second degree is
from Stanford also and
this person is thinking of the MA in
either education or public policy?
>> So I want to delineate a difference
between demanding versus commitment and
challenging.
So taking on a second degree, it's
a commitment, and if you're fully aware of
the ramifications of that choice in the
beginning, it shouldn't be a painful one.
>From an academic perspective,
all of our students have been academically
successful in our joint degree programs.
So what you're really navigating
in regards to demanding or
challenging is what electives
are you going to take when and
how do you spend your time outside of
the classroom when you have homework,
class preparation and
other activities that you want to do.
So it's really more around
priority management,
time management,
then it is about like overall demanding.
>> What about the more technical
degrees like electrical engineering or
computer science, how demanding are they?
>> Yeah.
Those I would consider more demanding,
especially in regards to time.
So for example students have shared
with me that one class can sometimes
be 20 to 25 hours of work
outside of the classroom.
>> Wow.
>> So this is not a degree for
the faint of heart.
[LAUGH]
>> Right, okay.
May I apply to a joint degree after
being accepted to the MBA program?
Is it more competitive than applying
to the regular MBA program?
>> So I think we've spoken to this
already that yes, you can apply after.
And it is not more competitive than
when you're applying during the MBA
initial cycle, as mentioned earlier,mother
application requirements are all the same,
regardless when you apply.
>> For programs that require travel
between two universities, how
well can students really create a strong
connection to the Stanford community.
>> So when we talk about connection to
the community, I think what we're really
talking about are student relationships,
and from what I have seen, students have
been able to maintain a strong sense of
connection through these relationships.
What I also notice is students
tend to be fully immersed and
present in their actual location.
So if they're here at the GSB,
they're fully here at the GSB and
the same is true for the other program.
And so, if you're at your other
institution you're taking full advantage
of the resources and
the people that are there,
so I don't think you have the same
sense of missing out here.
And all of our students still have access
to the all the GSB's online resources and
also staff are available to connect
over the phone or video chat.
So I think students can remain as
connected to the GSB as they want to be.
>> Students have told me that it's really
a chance to enlarge their own community
and they pretty much end up sort
of doubling their network at
not only two different universities but
two different departments on campus.
>> Another question here, I would love
to learn more about how distinct or
integrated we should make the applications
especially with regard to the essays,
is some overlap in our
responses to the essays.
I'll go ahead and answer that one.
MBA Admissions only reads the two essays
that are required for our application and
those are this year what matters most
to you and why, and why Stanford.
We would expect that you would address
your interest, and your rationale for
the second degree in the Y Stanford essay.
The other degree program typically
does not have access to or
read the essays required for the MBA.
So yes there will of course be
some overlap in the essays,
as they're for a separate audience.
I'm not quite sure if this person is
asking how much overlap there could
be between the two MBA essays,
the what matters most to you and why and
the why Stanford,
that's really entirely up to you.
Both essays are read by
the MBA admissions office.
How distinct or
integrated the two essays are, of course,
depends on what you're writing about.
So for example, if what matters most
to you relates to your reasons for
pursuing two degrees, there could
be a real overlap in the topic.
If what most matters most to you
is distinct from your interest in
the two degrees,
there may be no overlap in the essays.
Here's a question about JD-MBA.
For JD-MBAs, students,
do you have enough time to establish
strong relationships with both your GSB
and Stanford Law School classmates?
Which we sort of addressed, but
any further comments there Mary?
>> Yeah, I would just say, yes.
Yes, there is time.
In part because students typically
spend one full year, at least,
immersed at the law school.
And then,
another full year immersed at the GSB.
So you are able to connect
with your colleagues.
And I think right in the blended years is
where it's a little bit more challenging.
Because you have two communities and
two full sets of activities as options.
>> Here's a question about
Masters in Education.
Can I apply separately to the MBA and
the MA in Education so
in case I'm not admitted to the GSB,
I can still pursue the MA in Education?
If I am able to apply
separately the same year, and
I am admitted to both degrees,
can I pursue them as a joint degree.
>> This is a good nuanced question.
So the MA in education,
MBA program is only for
students who are admitted
to both programs.
So if you are not accepted to the GSB, you
would need to apply to a different program
at the graduate school of education and I
would encourage you to visit their website
as they'll have more information
on the on the options.
>> Another common question we get, Mary
about school of education is if the joint
masters with education includes
a teaching credential and it does not.
Correct?
>> Yes, that is correct.
Although the graduate school of
education offers a teaching credential,
it is not part of
the joint master's Program.
>> We'll pursuing a dual
degree burnout students and
this student is interested in MS and
Computer Science.
>> So,
let's talk about what causes burnout.
In my mind,
burnout is taking on too much without
the resources to make it sustainable.
So yes, the computer science degree
program requires extensive hours outside
of the classroom and that means that you
need to be willing to prioritize and
make trade-offs in order
to find a sustainable path.
But again, I spoke about this earlier.
If there's alignment between the program
and your goals, then there's a connection.
And so, those trade-offs shouldn't
be too difficult to make.
>> For students who are interested
in doing both the MA and
a Master's in Public Policy at Stanford
is less than the current average
work experience for an MBA,
which is four years average acceptable.
So if somebody has three years or
two years, is that okay?
This is admissions questions,
again, I'll take that.
There is no requirement for
the number of years work experience for
the MBA program or for any joint or
dual degree program, as far as I know.
How many students per
year pursue a degree with
a Harvard Kennedy School concurrently
with an MBA from the GSB?
And if somebody is applying to
the MBA program in this coming cycle,
would they be applying to start in 2018?
>> We have approximately 10 to 15 students
each year that are doing the program
with the Harvard Kennedy School and a
recommendation in regards to applying for
the GSB is that you should be applying for
the year that you wish to start.
>> And so, somebody would apply to
Harvard Kennedy this coming cycle
and then-
>> They should wait until next year to
apply to the GSB.
>> Okay, got it.
What have graduates of Stanford's joint
masters education accomplished as
a result of their experience at Stanford?
>> So I think what you're asking here is
what careers have these student gone onto,
let me give you a sampling of the areas.
They've gone into tech startups.
International schools,
charter schools, higher education,
administration and education investing,
just to name a few.
>> Well, we're almost out of time.
If you didn't get your
question answered today,
please feel free to contact our office
by email or phone to ask your questions.
Before we go, Mary, any words of
advice for our listeners today?
>> Yeah, so I think pursuing a joint or
a dual degree can be a wonderful
opportunity and it's something to be done
with purposeful reflection and intention.
Given that for many of you coming to
graduate school is a one time occurrence,
it really makes sense to be efficient
with your time, to maximize your
interdisciplinary learning and
to make use of your financial resources.
So, my best piece of advice for
you is try to get as clear as you
can on what you want to learn and
then just make sure that the program
you're applying to meets that need.
So, your expectations are realistic and
aligned.
And hopefully, they're met.
Good luck on that.
>> Thank you, Mary and thank you to
everyone out there for joining us.
An audio recording of this conference call
will be posted on our website in the next
few weeks.
The previous three calls in our
MBA Admissions Insights series are already
posted there, so take a look at those.
The current application is
now available on our website.
Again, there are three application
deadlines, September 21,
January 10 and April 5.
On our website,
you'll find videos of webinars and
a calendar of events offered
both on an oncampus and
around the world We look forward to
meeting you online or in person.
Goodbye for now.